[jazzy music]
♪ ♪
- Oof.
Another round?
- No, I think I'm good.
- It's open bar.
- Let's get another round.
- Yeah, let's get another round.
Come on.
- What a fun night.
- Yeah.
- I don't even care
if we win.
- Oh, we're gonna win.
- Yeah, of course, totally,
but I'm saying
even if we don't win--
- Yeah, we're gonna.
- Yeah, no, I know.
I mean, same page.
I'm just saying that,
you know, I'm so proud
of the work that we've done
that I don't need
the validation of my peers
to make me feel good about it.
- Yeah. But we're gonna win.
- Yes.
- Hey, how ya doin'?
I'll have four Boston Coolers.
But put some booze in 'em.
- Can I have
four White Russians?
Maybe put some booze in that?
- You know what?
Four more Boston Coolers.
No booze.
I'll tell you what.
You know what?
Put some booze in them.
A little booze in those.
- Wow, you guys must be thirsty.
- Carter?
Carter Grant,
VP of marketing, Chrysler?
- Well, not anymore.
- Oh, you changed your name?
- No, same name.
Um, I actually got fired.
- What happened?
- Well, I've hit a string
of bad luck as of late.
It all started
with that accident I was in.
You guys remember that?
[rock music]
♪ ♪
- Doesn't ring a bell.